cancer is our best friend it's our
highest opportunity we have right now to
say oh my gosh this is the signal that
our own bodies are losing touch with
itself and manifesting this this state
of loneliness and we would call cancer
instead of warring against that if we
would love those cells back into our
body we would disappear this whole
condition
I believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we really want and I want
to help give you the tools to make that
happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast I
say that in a very serious way because
today dr. Zack Bush is on and look
you're probably not going to understand
all of the things said on the show today
as I didn't but that doesn't matter in
the context that he puts this
information forward to help you
understand more about the body the
environment and how it all interacts
with each other is the fundamental is
the is what you're gonna get from it
it's not you don't have to know all the
words are and all the science behind it
but it's really cool to hear the
explanation and then how it applies to
you and the things that you need to do
to you know essentially like build a
better body we I mean I feel like this
is one of those episodes that I need to
listen to a few times so I collect the
information
integrate and and really remember but a
huge takeaway is just that look gut
health is really important he has a deep
history of medical knowledge that wants
to make you think that you know in the
medical world as he said it wants to
make you think that it's complicated and
there's lots of diseases and lots of
lots of magic potions to try and make
you better and and and medicines but
it's a lot more simple than that
so please enjoy today's episode
I do think it's important that everybody
understands the depth of your medical
accomplishments and your education so
that we can transition and to where
you're at now because it gives to me and
to everyone it's going to give such a
validity to it instead of it being you
know something that you've been a
certain way of thinking that you've had
all along
you started out extremely integrated in
the medical field and excelled and then
things shifted so here we go so you
completed med school in 2002 you're one
of the few triple board-certified
physicians you got the James Warning
Award for outstanding scholarship in the
field of internal medicine and then
after you did your internship and
residency they asked you to stay on
another year as chief resident you were
accepted into the prestigious
endocrinology fellowship at the
University of Virginia and then you went
on to three years of research did I kind
of check whoever's doing your research
is doing a deeper than those people's
good little details out of the John
Waring award and internal medicine
that's not a well-known awards and press
you guys found that one a real warning
huh mercy am i writing isn't as good as
the research but anyway the point is is
that you've clearly excelled you did you
had a ton of Education and then you went
into three years of research and this is
kind of where things change so maybe you
can explain the research that you were
doing and what made what gave you what
seems like a paradigm shift yeah in this
case it wasn't necessarily a single
moment but more like a cold coalescence
of maybe five or six moments that came
together around 2008 to 2010 the field
of medicine was changing a lot partially
because of economics and so the the
collapse of the economy that happened in
2008 had a huge influence on the
National Institutes of Health and their
funding
my research was suddenly caught up in
this storm of collapse of financial
footing underneath a lot of the
universities but coherent with that
moment of financial stress my
intellectual model of how human biology
happened started to go under some severe
stressors itself and challenges to that
paradigm and it was coming out of the
experience of doing my cancer research
on the microscope and then seeing
diabetes and autoimmune disease in
clinic as an endocrinologist
simultaneously and so it's kind of this
collision of these two big different
subspecialties of medicine and there was
a day that I was watching tumors
infiltrates healthy tissue and that
you've actually seen this pattern many
times anybody who's flown in an airplane
has seen this pattern that when you see
a city spread across Prairie and long
highway lines and everything else that
looks identical to cancer moving through
tissue the patterns of growth followed
that same behavior of our cities and
their growth patterns as it as if it was
the inside the city and going out yes
you have highways that stretch out and
the way in which bands form around that
and infrastructure comes around a
highway system is very much the same way
biology works and so you have to have
supply lines you have to have you know
movement of materials and resources it's
very much a city infrastructure of a
team rebuilding its own you know
infrastructure and so I'm experiencing
that and going through that kind of
space and then suddenly realize I'm
running late to clinic throw on a white
coat act like I'm a doctor with Ronis
tesco walk in and suddenly there's a
patient there that I've never met and
the whole room smells horrible and his
chief complaint is he's got this huge
infected diabetic ulcer and ankle and so
then for the next half hour I'm down in
this wound and this guy's ankle and I'm
dissecting tissue trying not to throw up
and then suddenly there's a moment where
I'm looking at healthy tissue and then
the infiltration of dying tissue inside
of it as this necrotic tissue and it was
exactly the same pattern of the tumor I
just saw and it was one of those
singularity moments was like oh my gosh
I kept I thought all of these things
were different I was taught that there's
all these different paths
for the ologies and complex systems and
what if there was only one thing which
is vitality and the lack thereof health
and the lack of health and the lack of
health then allows for disease or
dysfunction to start to materialize in
that vacancy of vitality and suddenly I
realized that I'd spent you know 20
years of my life and school debt house
mortgage worth of school debt going down
the wrong path believing everything was
complicated and suddenly thought yeah
what if everything was super simple and
as a physician all I really had to do
was figure out health and I had zero
preparation for that I had no idea what
human health was I had no idea what
would supply a cell to be a healthy
biologic system and so that was really
where the paradigm started as shift was
what if there was no such thing as
disease and only apostasy yeah that's
big I mean that would be the way deep
real quick but but uh you know dis-ease
in the body or disease of the body and
how you know where does that really come
from and is it manifested versus is it
real and and what is what is the fabric
of it you know what what is the real
what is the real cure and again the
complication of like you know pills
needles IVs surgeries you know all these
drug companies making billions of
dollars when I mean even like as a
simple example I was sponsored by one
care which was a company that tries to
find the cure for cancer in dogs but
it's it called one care because it will
care people too and that it's all really
the same and so I mean what happy now
what did you do next I slipped into
major depression like my I really
couldn't I couldn't put it all together
fast enough as to what the solution was
gonna be for my my life pattern that or
path at that point it was so well mning
at the time I was doing chemotherapy
research I was developing
chemotherapy for tumors and the that
realization of maybe there is no such
thing of disease was quickly followed by
the realization that not a single cancer
in human history has ever been caused by
a lack of chemotherapy and that simple
moment was just said to me it doesn't
matter how smart you get no matter how
you know brilliant you think you are as
a drug discovery unit or whatever it is
you're going down the wrong path you
will never find what you hope to find
which is something to help your patients
and there and I think we for the most
part all go into medicine very
altruistic alee and yet we're caught up
immediately in a machine that's not
there for human health but but for for
monetary gain and our research is funded
by it our education is built around it
and so in a sense it is fashion we go
from altruistic I want to heal the world
I want to be this you know advocate for
my patients to what does the insurance
gonna reimburse me how do I keep my
clinic afloat you know how do I pay off
my school debt in academia you know I
was on faculty at the University of
Virginia and making $75,000 a year and
had $150,000 of school debt to kids
heading towards college like I was
indentured servitude because I couldn't
there was no way I could pay off
everything and and said middle level
managers at McDonald's were making more
than I did as that is the system that's
the system go into debt I have to work
because you have work because you have
to work don't question anything be more
wrapped up in the drama of paying your
bills than the reality of what's going
on so you had mentioned I mean one of
the fundamentals that I believe in and
as a my fundamental but possibly
conspiracy is that there's no there's no
money in wellness
I mean these drug companies have really
what why would they be trying to cure
you when then they won't use their
product anymore right why would they
want you to know what makes you well why
would they want you to eat really good
why would the hospital give you the [ __ ]
that you're supposed to eat instead of
they're giving you you know more more
yogurt more jell-o's more jell-o's more
you know rolls more McDonald's there's
McDonald's and Gruen in hospitals I mean
that is just ludicrous so you had
mentioned that the you know these are
all my ramblings of frustrations because
you know I believe in food as being a
medicine and that you know Big Pharma
and you know you know I dread that that
uh these pharmaceutical studies and you
hadn't just mentioned you know who funds
them what are they for of course if they
fund them they fund them in themselves
right yeah I mean in the end you have
money running drug development drug
development running education education
and following back into you know the
money development piece and so as a
complete closed-loop and in medicine I
think is one but I say at this point in
the United States we could say the same
thing about banking and finance you know
the people who are teaching those
business courses or the people that
created the status quo of you know
banking at the cost of humanity or
whatever it is you know so at each point
we've created these closed loops of
belief systems that drive education and
when the belief system drives the
education a paradigm shift becomes very
challenging to to manifest and so in
human behavior patterns that we've seen
through all the time there's no way that
the current paradigm is going to change
until absolute crisis hits us what would
that look like it looks like the last
five years and so we are in the largest
crisis we've ever seen in human history
describe the crisis what crisis are you
talking what there's a whole lot of
crisis is out there but what are you
talking about so the crisis were in the
midst of right now is what is fondly
called the sixth extinction on the
planet we haven't seen this fast or
rapid a decline in biology on the
surface of the planet since about fifty
five nine years ago when the dinosaurs
went extinct so this would be the bees
and things like that that we're seeing
is that part of that yeah so you hear
about bees you hear about you know
some of the loss of big animal life and
you hear of endangered species you hear
all this but what you don't hear about
is that we've actually killed 40% of
biology on the planet in the last 50
years so I'm almost halfway done wiping
out how all biology and so to have that
vast effect on all of biology on the
planet you start to realize that human
biology collapse that we've seen over
the last twenty years which is this
chronic disease explosion that we've had
has to be tied up in a bigger story than
Oh human health just sucks because we
eat McDonald's know if it was just a
problem with McDonald's then we would
simply have a human problem but we are
wiping out biology at every fractal from
the virus all the way up to macro life
like humans and large animals and ocean
animals and the rest and so to create
create that big of a shift in the
ability of biology to survive we must
have did something fundamental to the
fabric of biology what is that the
fabric of biology really comes down to a
catch term that's being thrown around
with a lot of misperceptions right now
which is the microbiome and the
microbiome is a description of an
environment or large ecosystem of tiny
bugs and so you've got viruses at the
bottom of that and as far our size and
kind of magnitude of spread so I
consider the viruses as the foundation
sitting on top of that you have the
fungi fungi have some five million
species and so we we think we get a
fancy grocery store when we have four or
five species of mushroom something on
there and love mushrooms yeah
five million species oh whoa I haven't
even started yeah you got a ways to go
and you're calling away for the time off
they're all fun no matter what lunch of
fun guys and say you got that whole
explosive you know fungal Kingdom
sitting on top of this viral
intelligence and then sitting on that as
the parasites you got 300,000 species of
parasites and these guys are kind of the
first semblance of multicellular
organisms that would be kind of
you know predecessors to the worms and
you know the things you think of as
being the soil kind of architects out
there but sitting on top of the parasite
kingdom then is the bacterial kingdom
and we may have 30 or 40,000 species of
bacteria that are critical to this
biologic system so you got by hearses
fungi the parasites in the bacteria
created this large ecosystem and then
somewhere wait wait wait up in this
almost pixel of life on Earth is
humanity and one way to look at the
scale of all of this is genetics the
human species is almost non-existent
genetically we have only 20,000 genes
that's really pathetic cuz we already
knew by the time we figured out we had
20,000 genes we knew that the fruit fly
had 13,000 genes and we knew that the
flea had 30,000 genes so you fall
somewhere between a flea and a fruit fly
when it comes to genetic complexity and
that's very fascinating when you think
of the system that we build out of those
many or 20,000 genes and so you then
compare that to let's say the bacteria
the bacteria with their 30,000 species
have two million genes
that's that family then we go to the
parasites those 300,000 species of pairs
parasites have around 2 billion genes
and then you go down to the funded I and
we're on five million species of fungi
and now you're looking at 125 trillion
genes and then you go down to the
viruses and we don't even know how many
species of viruses the rough estimate
that we currently have a number of
viruses on earth is ten to the 31 that's
a one with 31 zeros after we don't have
a name for that number that's to put
that in perspective on the on the kind
of the galactic or universal scale
that's ten million times more than our
stars in the entire universe and so ten
to the 31 viruses and so really I wake
up every morning and just so thankful
that our senators of Disease Control and
figured out how to vaccinate us against
three flu viruses every year it's really
ludicrous when we think about our
concept of vaccinations like we're
trying to protect ourselves from what
we've got ten to the 31 viruses on the
planet that's so abundant with you know
quadrillions of genes that are affecting
our your 40,000 genes and then we think
of the fungi and we got 125
in genes that are affecting our genes
and then we get the so you start going
down and you realize there's absolutely
no way that human life came into
existence without not only the allowance
of the microbiome letting us be there
but only by the provision of the
intelligence of the genetic genomic of
the microbiome of the world that we
exist what do you mean by that what I
mean by that is that as we've started to
untangle what the genome actually is we
realized the plasticity and the
interconnectedness of the genetics we
used to believe when I went through
Medical School and 92 that 96 was this
really exciting time where we were
decoding the human genome and that
four-year period and by the time I was
you know hitting medical school and
towards the end of that period I was
told that I would be the first
generation of physicians that would be
able to do what we called personalized
medicine where I'd go into a room would
ask no questions swab their mouth run a
genomics profile and know exactly what
diseases they would have and what drugs
they would respond to and whether or not
they should have children or not and all
these things and so we really were
calling calling this personalized
medicine like it was gonna be so
personal that it wasn't like I'd had to
look at population to figure out what
would be so that was the promise and
that really wasn't should be called like
naked medicine because that's rough yeah
okay keep going all right but then
within two years of that we find out we
only have 20,000 genes but we knew we
had 250,000 proteins
coming from those mirror 20,000 genes so
what that meant is we had completely the
wrong model of DNA which was very
disruptive and didn't make many
headlines because I think we were so
insecure at the time that we didn't
really want to talk much about that in
public we wanted people to really
believe we had figured out this whole
Watson and what's the consequence of
that the consequence was that we had no
idea how life began again oh [ __ ] aliens
were there already god we're there and
so if if DNA doesn't predict if the gene
doesn't predict the protein that it's
gonna go and make if it's not the
blueprint for the protein that's gonna
what's determining that what is really
driving life
and what's driving the plasticity of
life consciousness and so well you just
spread right to the answer this is the
most efficient conversation I've ever
had are fantastic and that's it thanks
everybody for joining no am I completely
uh I mean is that anything to do with it
it has to have something to do with it
because I just you know as we're asking
what is it what is DNA alchemy and how
does it interact with its greater system
I guess we can answer that real quick
before we get into the the mirror image
of that which is the consciousness piece
but what we found first was this
phenomenon of epigenetics which was a
gene can be modified by methylation
patterns which was kind of a
biochemistry modification on the surface
of that gene to make sure that it can
turn on or off at the right times or be
modified to determine what it could
would produce as far as which protein
and would go to produce so epigenetics
was the first but it's something that
you could control epigenetics is
something that you have some control
over you have some control of it but I'd
say that and what's really controlling
that is your environment okay and so
okay if you know a big storm blows in
big bolt of lightning and Sutton's clap
of thunder and you go into a startle or
a reaction you just changed over 2,000
genes and sent aeneas lee from an
epigenetic modification of a
fight-or-flight Gaudette state okay and
so that environment around you your
genome has developed over the hundreds
of thousands of years we've been around
two hundred thousand years but the the
genomic progress towards the the species
of Homo sapiens sapiens had to be
layered on top of this this learning
experience of the environment shifting
the genes and and making them behave
differently and so we're very very
plastic on that level but then in the
last kind of six seven years as we've
discovered micro RNA that are produced
they're the messengers that are produced
from your junk DNA so I told you it's
junk DNA yeah when you look at a nature
I think you just are overwhelmed by the
amount of junk right Mother Earth is
just like full of beautiful junk but it
doesn't do junk like that it's that
we've gone down to this base belief that
there was functional DNA that would
cause and create a gene and the
98.5% of the genome was junk is a pretty
extraordinary leap of Hubert's there
then since we couldn't figure out what
the 98.5% was doing because it wasn't
making a gene we went on to just call
that junk DNA kind of like kind of like
dark matter what it is so we just call
it dark matter yeah because this is the
exact same thing we can't describe 96%
of the universe and so we're gonna call
that dr. dark matter exists and so we're
gonna make a fudge factor number for
dark matter I'm going to put that into
every physics equation act like we know
how the universe works we did the same
thing in genomics only to find out that
of course the 98.5 percent of the genome
that we used deem jugg is the most
important part in the sense that it
creates these little tiny singling
molecules that are called micro RNA that
do something very cool which is leave
the human cell and so DNA turns into RNA
turns into a protein and that can turn
into an enzyme or any structural
function within the cell and that's all
very cool but micro RNA gets to leave
the human cell and go into your
bloodstream and ultimately in this short
amount of time that we've been talking
I've modified your genomics by breathing
you've done a good job I hope that
epigenetic environment I'm in wills yeah
the balance the body you manifest
tomorrow will depend on this interaction
we're having right now and so we're
modifying each other through micro RNA
that we're secreting in our breath and
they go in these little pockets these
little exosomes that are secreting our
saliva in our lining of our lungs we
breathe these out in the environment and
it interacts with the genomes all around
us and so if there's an insect in the
room I can modify that genome but
interestingly that that insect has a
micro RNA that's going out into the
system we can modify me this evolution
then I'm some sort
you know MIT singularity like we no
longer afternoon can really hold the
space of like yeah this species is this
species no this species is genomically
swapping information all the time and
all the other species are modifying this
one and as we've started to just start
to untangle I told you how vast the
microbiome is
get ours and whereas we start to
untangle what is the source of the micro
RNA in your bloodstream we already know
that at least 30% of the micro RNA and
I'm sure we're gonna find out that 99%
of your micro RNA is not human do you
were gonna say that I was like it's not
ours is it so at least 30% we've already
figured I was coming from the bacteria
and the fungi alone and we haven't even
started untangle the viruses and
parasites yet but with at least 30
percent of micro RNA coming from
bacteria and fungi and those micro RNA
will then go insert themselves back into
your cells travel into the nucleus and
bind to areas within the genome that
would then go on to decide what that
that gene is going to make we now know
that any single gene can make anywhere
from 200 maybe 2,000 different protein
yeah outcomes that's kind of like saying
a blueprint of a house could build 2,000
different houses depending on the
environment in which that blue thread is
rolled out and that's literally what
happens DNA is packaged around these
tiny little balls called histones and it
has to unravel and amazingly and every
one of your microscopic cells they're 6
feet of DNA no less 6 feet of DNA
wrapped up around these tiny little
histones and so that it can be packaged
down small enough to become a chromosome
you may be heard that we have 46
chromosomes you get 23 for Mom
23 from dad they come together you have
46 chromosomes they then have to unwind
at the right spot to make make available
one tiny little strip of DNA six feet of
DNA by a way is kind of a big number
when you're thinking microscopically but
when you start to put your 70 trillion
cells together then it gets to be a
really bizarre thought the DNA in your
body if we started a string and
end-to-end would wrap around mother
earth 2 million times and so then we
took a 15 minute break and I got my
brain back in order again you wrap
around mother at 20 times and that DNA
has to repair itself every day and so
there's enzymes as if along your DNA and
do repairs and so you're repairing your
DNA every time we walk out in sunshine
millions and millions of base pairs
damaged throughout the whole body and
that needs to repair constantly so you
have this universe this factory of of
repair that's always in motion and
simultaneously you have this plasticity
happening where you're responding to the
bacteria in your gut what they just ate
and they're modifying your behavior and
so not only this what they'd call
neuroplasticity then as far as being
able to take in
maybe that's the consciousness element I
don't know I mean but neuroplasticity is
yeah for sure yeah so neuroplasticity is
actually where I got my first rib this
was like late 1990s I started working
with Phillip gold at the NIH around
psycho neuroendocrinology was the little
nation where it doesn't even need to be
dissected at this moment but psycho nor
endocrinology was the description that
your mood could modify your brain and
what we now find out you know thirty
years later is or 20 years later we're
now seeing this phenomenon that the back
turn your gut and their response to the
food you just put in your mouth can
modify the neurologic synapse or the the
production of neurotransmitters that
your gut lighting that will then go
modify your macro behavior and we now
know that a changing microbiome can
cause major depression anxiety disorder
or in fact cancers and everything else
so the neuro plasticity that you refer
to is the concept that a brain can
change and as of 1992 we didn't think
that was possible you were born with the
neurons you had and you slowly lost
neurons over the course of your life and
that was where you were stuck and if you
lost a neuron that was that was just
dumb luck and you could never get that
back when we found out that you could
actually birth neurons all the time
that was an exciting moment and it turns
out that well for women it's it's you
have a huge advantage is that every time
you have a menstrual cycle you you burn
new neurons very quickly these dendritic
and not only our neurons starting to
read F er ng a you actually get an
explosion of dendrites at the end of
them the dendrites are like the network
coming out the end of a neuron to
connect to other neurons and so women
have the ability to make new
connectivity within the brain every
morning is there any connection to when
a baby is growing they have a lot of
what's the thrill of DMT oh yeah DMT and
and that is like a life force energy and
so on a smaller scale you have your
cycle those babies don't become real but
as they're like DMT in that does that
help what is that I mean I can't even
say the word that it stands for but it's
like a you know it's a good you used to
raise cars or something I did okay
you've got an interest in reading or
like I do I do I do I do
all right so yeah well we all carry DMT
within us at all times learn that we yes
we all have it but but there's a there's
a there's a lot more of it and a baby
and when it's bent when it's growing is
this true the amount of DMT in the brain
is DMT is produced just like any other
neurotransmitter chemical in the body so
it's produced all the time so it's not
like there was a huge reservoir in the
baby but if the release of it comes at
very predictable moments at the moment
of Labor for example when a child is
born there's a huge DMT released from
mom and baby in that phase the other
place why you can smile after it's over
within that's why you would have two
children and so yeah there's a media
erasure of what you the trauma you may
have just gone through or the extreme
and so DMT release puts you in that kind
of what might be referred to as that god
moment where you have the sense of huge
connectivity to nature and creation
itself and yeah this like high of I am
omnipotent and yeah like capacity yes
you know production of life and so you
suddenly forgot that last you know three
days were some of the most intense
painful experiences you've ever had in
your life and and so that kind of
experience is there but then on the
other side of what we call life this
death moment we see the same phenomenon
of huge DMT release happening in this
phase and of course we can use you know
plant medicines or drugs synthetic drugs
to try to release DMT and other hormones
and stuff around that to give us some
sort of sense of singularity though
you know in the tribal medicine worlds
ayahuasca mosque is the classic but then
you can see the same thing with breath
work and so we do a lot of working like
with just hold the trumpet breathing and
all this because you can get again lease
and get people in this I see Gabby Reece
and Laird Hamilton they have the program
xpt but they of course work a taunt they
do a ton of breath work and so sometimes
after I work Gabi holds a work out every
morning basically and you can go so in
her gym workouts because gym and pool
workouts and in the gym workouts
she'll sometimes do a breathing exercise
afterwards but even in the pool workout
the other day when I was there there was
a group of guys that was doing you know
they were you know riding an assault
bike in a sauna because that's what you
do and you have to wear oven mitts
because otherwise you'll burn your hands
on the handles cuz you know I wouldn't
show you just got me smart right or the
gloves I mean the oven mitts anyway they
get out there laying on the ground and I
think man those guys are dead and I
would be too assault bike without a
sauna is deadly but then you start then
they then they've been there awhile and
I'm thinking they're really fit they're
probably not dying and then they sit up
and they start and doing breath work and
like Gabi's sitting there laughing she's
like well like the man breathing or
something and so but you can get that
euphoric body buzz that feels like I
mean you know the like an orgasm like a
you know like a body orgasm where your
whole body is tingling and it's just
from breathing yeah yeah but they'd use
all those kinds of words neurotropic and
all those things and I don't know
anything about that but breathing is I
mean even when I think about it on a
simple level of like as a human being we
we are such shallow breathers we just
don't use much breath we have so much
more potential so except of the moment
of labor so child labor you go into a
whole trove of breathing unintentionally
like there's a you're forced
biologically to go into whole trope of
breathing when you're in labor what is
whole truck halitosis well is there a
certain way to accomplish that yeah very
hard out out push of air and then
there's a biologic response to that to
pull air in again so it's actually an
exhale more than it is a heart inhaling
focusing on exhale and when you watch
somebody in labor they're yelling at her
breathe breathe breathe and she's not
going she's going yeah yeah it's that
it's that intense output and there's an
immediate easy inhale laughter I want to
be able to recreate this after we're
done so how do you get that done I'll go
up in the stirrups I'll just go sit look
at the ocean but so you know all of
these things around this is to say that
we're understanding that things like DMT
release and breathing and physiologic
transitions from life birth and then
what we would call death somehow are
calling us into these moments of super
connectivity at the at the neurologic
level that really supersedes the neuron
at the point at that point you're having
experience where you're tied into
something that I would call quorum
sensing cuz I'm always in the microbiome
world but quorum sensing is a term that
came out of this understanding of
bacteria and fungi and how once you get
enough volume of a species of bacteria
or fungi you start to get a hyper
intelligence where that species starts
to do things that you can't really
figure out how they could possibly be
functioning in this high state of
intelligence so micro rise a and the
fungal world of the the kind of highways
and networks under soil are good
examples of this that if you dump
fertilizer in one area of a 40,000 acre
farm the micro Z will rarely rapidly
figure out where that needs to go in
that 40,000 acre farm and it will start
distributing nutrients and and resources
throughout the farm and so that's an
idea of hyper intelligence of like and
you'd think this guy cares about itself
is going to like sequester resources but
instead of sequestering resources they
do the opposite which is distribute
resources intelligently o'clock across
massive areas I feel like I've heard
that nature is all connected through the
ground yeah like it's all interconnected
through something happen under one tree
will connect to another tree
connectivity there and that's the fungi
that do that so the fungi are connecting
the trees and so for example the birch
tree is really interesting the birch
tree requires a very unique soil
nutrients or
root nutrients to grow and yet it always
grows in soil that lack those nutrients
and so that has to be within a certain
distance from a certain type of
evergreen or pine that produces those
nutrients and then the pine will pass to
the fungi those nutrients and will go
nurture a beech beech tree out of the
ground there and so there's this
relationship or intelligence of how do
we support the broadest amount of
diversity in an environment and the that
quorum sensing of that hyper
intelligence is coming through this
cooperative relationship to all these
and i think that's what i was-- kit does
and i think that's what you know
anything that would induce a DMT release
is also going to give you that hyper
intelligence that like okay i'm no
longer limited to this small physical
body but i'm actually interconnected
right to an entire planet and beyond
that a solar system and beyond that a
universe and all of that connectivity is
now no longer biologic but actually
about physics and that is also me
electrons and so at the biological level
we have fungi at the at the biophysics
level we have the passage and ends and
transfer of electrons and so through
those two mechanisms we have this
wireless communication network that ties
the entire university into a singular
hyper intelligence it's like the
internet really makes you question the
micro versus the macro right when you
look at things on a micro level
sometimes there's disorganization right
it's there's no there's another word for
it video chaos theory thank you but then
out of my um macro level things things
are organized and things are not things
don't follow the chaos theory is that
right
oh i don't think you can ever get away
from patterns at every level you've got
patterns there and so i mean even like
i'm we're talking about lucinda genex I
mean patterns are always emerging and
who is energetic the fundamental and
host yes yeah and so the patterns that
we can't see because of our perspective
and if you heard the word and felt it's
a german word but there's some great TED
talks on him felt but they um felt is
our our perception of the reality around
us and we achieve that through the
biologic structure of our eyeball
the biologic structure of our eardrums
and the way they interface with our
brain the biologic structure of our
tongue and the receptors there so the
way we sense the world is entirely based
on our biology which of course is
doesn't rule anything right our biology
is the result of all that genomic stuff
we talked about everything else then you
look at a bat and a bat perceives the
universe in a completely different way
right and so a rose is an interesting
concept so flower and we think oh yeah
Rose red rose the reality is a rose
fundamentally has absolutely no color to
it there's no redness about a rose the
only thing that gives a rose the the the
characteristic of red is actually the
biologic shape and structure of our eyes
and cones there and everything else and
so we then ascribe a color which is
actually just a frequency of vibration
of that structure and we've come to
choose that you know associate that
frequency as if it was a characteristic
of that that in our interpretation of
that frequency grows when a beam looks
at that flower sees nothing red sees no
color whatsoever and it seems a
vibration there and so it sees an
aberration in the electromagnetic field
and it's drawn into that space but it
has nothing to do with the color and so
the belt that we've created as humans
have really limited our capacity I think
to think to our full potential to do
quorum sensing on their level that we
would have the capacity and I'm you know
very intrigued by the possibility that
these these experiences of birth and DMT
release there or death and what happens
there are actually helping us in those
few seconds to divorce ourselves from
the limitations of our Moon felt that
our sensory perception of the reality
around us and that's that was one of my
major transformations that was happening
around the time that biologically I was
starting to lose the the belief of
disease at the same time as I was
starting to lose the belief of our kind
of concept of spirituality and
consciousness because I was having such
bizarre experiences in the icy use in a
nice that you get to see you know what
we call death all the time and sometimes
very few know four to six percent of the
time we managed to bring people back
from
through our resuscitation efforts and so
you might you know do compressions and
the drugs and the shocking everything
you see on ER or whatever TV show you've
seen all that stuff we do all the time
and very rarely works even in best case
scenarios but I had a couple very weird
nights in the ICU one in particular that
I was able to resuscitate three people
with my team in a single night and you
couldn't have picked three completely
different human beings one was you know
a an HIV patient I was dying from
complications of AIDS one was an African
American pastor who it was surrounded by
a like 250 of his extended family and
congregation who were just you know
always trying to get into his icy room
and it's extremely isolated estranged
from his family gentleman dying from
AIDS and then this kid who's dying at 18
who had some genetic disorders and bone
formation said it suffered hundreds of
thousands of fractures in his life and
was dying of complications of pneumonia
and so you just couldn't find three
different life experiences different
right managed to resuscitate all three
of these people and over the next 18
hours of being in the hospital with
these people and their families heard
them tell all the identical stories
about what they experienced between the
moment that their heart stopped in the
moment that we got their heart restarted
and in those seconds they all
experienced something that was really
bizarre and that they all experienced
not the white light and everything else
that you think of they they had an
overwhelming experience of full
acceptance you are completely accepted I
have a story about that um I was uh I
was in Tulum Mexico love that's why I
love that spot it's a super hippies area
very spiritual and
I am only gonna set it up because I have
no idea if it matters or not but it was
like day four word is it takes three
days to really integrate into the energy
of that space it's day four we go and do
a three-and-a-half hour yoga class with
a guy named Raphael shaman and trust me
he looks like a yogi he was doing like
we there was weird things happening but
Bennet even and there was lots of free
thing about three and a half hours then
I just said lots of breathing then we go
and get a chakra aligning massage then
we head back to because I'm a very I
think about the future a lot that's
probably one of my downfalls is that I
it can be good but it's also bad and
that I get very locked in I'm wanting to
accomplish something so there was a
great little spot called raw love that
has the best I know yeah Rolla and I'm
like I thought we were gonna have time
in between the yoga class and the
massage to go get a smoothie bowl or
something like that there or they're
like living pizza like raw pizza and and
we didn't so then of course ride the
bikes on back up all the way from y'all
and wellness all the way back up to raw
love which is a bike ride and we get it
and my we go get our smoothie bowls a
true love and my friend Stacy who was
with me she's just like buzzing floating
and I'm literally like you're annoying
me I need you to relax so we go back to
the place that we're staying and I said
I'm gonna go down onto the beach and
find us a spot it was kind of like later
afternoon it might be a different area
because I'm just gonna look at try and
find Sun so I go down there and none of
Sun I had to end up wandering back to
the original spot that we had been every
day and there was this there was this
dog from the very beginning of the trip
that kept coming around in its its
energy its it's its energy its frequency
was very like very much resonated with
me and I even said I gave the dog a name
I named it Lucy and I said that I feel
like I was a dog in another life
and then I said I feel like look loose I
feel like Lucy's me and so this and the
the energy of this dog was weird and
it's this push and pull way that if I
wanted to see the dog because it was
around like every day I couldn't find it
but as soon as I let go of the of that
the grasping at wanting something it
showed up and I was like oh god this is
so weird and so this dog showed up on
that spot and when the dog showed up it
was like a spiritual conduit to an
energy because I got that exact thing I
was sitting there I have no idea how
long it was I think it was seconds but I
start I felt this extremely overwhelming
feeling of total love and acceptance and
that no matter how long I have gone how
far away I've gone it's always there
there's no judgement total love total
acceptance and I just started bawling
and I was crying and crying and crying
and trying to keep my [ __ ] together in
public and then my friend Stacy comes
down finally because she was on the
phone and she came down and and I just
start going I started crying again I'm
like no it's okay I just it's the dog so
listen it was just that though it was
exactly that it was like I was able to
feel that frequency that's what it was
how I would say it's like I felt the
love frequency or God frequency or
source energy that's what I would go
completely right completely accept it
everything was perfect
nothing is wrong never has been and also
never will be I never will be and so was
that day for that was day for so let's
let's take a look at that four-day
period from this standpoint of the
microbiome because it's fascinating
oh and so I would argue that you
actually didn't have a human experience
at that point you had a microbiome
experience yeah which is to say that it
was through your home felt your sensory
processing that's
here's everything you did hmm but the
preparation for that was all in the
microbiome so it turns out that 72 hours
three days is exactly how long it takes
for your gut to completely turn over
your brand-new gut lining every three
days and when you shift into a
completely different environment so you
go from Southern California to Tulum
Mexico the microbiome could not be you
know more different in those two spaces
in the sense and on top of that you have
biophysics you have resonance
frequencies that are geologically
determined right so that's Southern Cal
ya has its own geology its own resonance
frequencies coming out of Tulum super
weird energy there everybody that's ever
been there it's got the opportunity to
feel that experience if there is simply
just a different biological or
biophysics resonance in that space and
then you put a microbiology on that
that's totally different you know the
first three days reason why it takes you
three days to downshift is because in
those first day you're still receiving
the information your brain is reserving
their information for the microbiome of
Southern California so no matter how
much your belt is experiencing something
different yeah
your brain is primary input of the brain
is actually the microbiome 90 percent of
the serotonin made that will end up in
your brain is made in your gut lining
and so your brain is really being
controlled by or the input into your
brain is is determined by the microbiome
and its presence there so over those the
first three days in Tulum you go through
a complete transformation that got
lining not a single cell in your
billions of cells that lined your gut
and interfaced with that that
microbiology is the same three days
later so your cells resonating in a new
frequency are now sensing a new
microbiome that is imprinted and there's
nothing that accelerates microbiome
shift and human being I believe more
than a dog and so here this dog comes
into your life and this dog is
accelerating your experience of the
microbiome of two why because that dog
lives in the soil and so it's digging
around it's running around as well sure
I laid with it I mean I was petting it a
inter up in it right yep oh yeah there's
a picture of us like third eye
connection like we were like like this
yeah
when we're done I'll show you the like
your face sure sure yeah of course what
do dogs do the first time they mean they
sniff both sniff butts yes I really
believe that dog species was the first
to really discover the importance of the
microbiome because they recognized if
you're gonna go see somebody you need to
understand their microbiome before you
go listening to what they have to say
they said don't smell that's right so
you sniff each others butts like each
other's budget really good microbiome
and then you go and lick the face of the
human and at that moment you got a dog
transplant I'm not just LC you got the
entire dog population of tulum licked in
your face for the next three days you
adapted to this information of not where
Tulum is today but thousands of
generations of the street dogs of Tulum
are interacting with you in that moment
and that's coding a new resonance
frequency human cell that's receiving
the information the microbiome you start
to get a sense which is how crazy
limited it is to think that we are human
like we we are simply the central
processing unit of mother earth herself
and we are there to pick up information
process that information and have the
opportunity to do quorum sensing and
hyper intelligence as a species and you
know I don't think we've ever stepped
into that role I think that we are so
busy drawing differences between each
other not only not believing that we're
part of nature we don't even believe
that we're part of other human being
well the division we create out there
you're this you're that you're black
you're white you're a man you're a woman
you're from Africa you're from China
I run a company now about Hunter
employees or whatever in the space and I
find it fascinating that here's a 100
people within seven billion people they
live and work in the same space they all
have the same goal and yet their brains
are still able to draw division between
each other and find differences that's
extraordinary
our veldt seems tailor-made to see
differences rather than singularity and
so that's that's the one limitation of
our species why do you think that is
then because I think it's also our
greatest opportunity yes I think that
our test as humans that is that our gift
and our curse I think it's our journey
our
journeys into this opportunity to use
that in felt capacity to see the nuance
of self-identity understand it respect
it value it and then co-create with it I
don't think that other species
especially go down to bacteria and fungi
I think they lack the ability or it's
not even a bill ability it makes it
sound like it's some sort of better
thing they don't do self-identity humans
are very unique and primates are unique
in their self-identity capacity and so I
think it's in this journey towards
understanding that I am a very unique
being with a very ancient purpose that
showed up right now to interface a very
complex biophysics thing that we might
call a soul or spirit or just energy and
depending on your worldview that soul is
now interfacing with a very weird little
shell of biology and biology is a
fraction of the reality around us right
so just like we're talking about the DNA
if we just look at the fabric of the
universe we live in its 99.999 5% vacuum
space and so with that 0.001 percent
solid we then create biology and we just
assume the biology rules everything all
genetics believe in biology and we
believe in this stuff in fact it's just
a little bit a tiny bit of solid stuff
that's aligning itself to a biophysics
event right the actual matter real
matter is really doesn't make up for
much right it's mostly just energy so
the real question is then how do we
change this info how do we how do we how
can we reshape our lives how can we
reshape the way we see things how do we
shift our perception I think that we we
have to start as a society dogs licking
you by certainly by starting to do a lot
more but like even about like games just
take that any way you want but I think
that where we're going with this is that
when you see bacteria with an unfettered
amount of information they start to do
this hyper intelligence
same way in my cancer labs what we see
now so I left academia but started my
own lab in 2012 and we take a very
different approach now to looking at
cancer cells they no longer are a
disease they're just the most lonely
cell in the body and if you reconnect
that cell to a larger ecosystem of human
cells the cancer qualities of that cell
go away or if it can't overcome that
limitation then it just kills itself and
disappears and so cancer is a cell
that's become so isolated from its
greater organism that it's forgotten
that there's life other than itself and
so now it's just on a mission to survive
it's definitely the most damaged cell in
the body and so you have this highly
damaged highly lonely cell and there are
approach now in clinic or in a basic
science lab is to try to bring enough
information to that cell a cell with
unfettered information always knows
exactly what to do for the greater good
and so if it's cancer cell that can't
heal itself and return to a cooperative
relationship with this environment it
kills itself you don't need to talk sin
you don't need radiation you don't need
to cut it out with a knife it simply
kills itself and so it doesn't need does
it need cell communication to make that
happen or can I do it on its own no
can't do it on its own it's like people
just welcome everyone in inclusion yeah
come on in here and look at school
shootings as an example of that we
should we
in hindsight go and figure out how that
kid became isolated two years before the
school shooting and oppression all the
thing these shootings are just the the
macro version of cancer where here's an
organism that was part of a seven
billion celled organism called humanity
right not isolated started to get
damaged couldn't repair because it
couldn't understand its greater
ecosystem couldn't get enough
information to understand its role and
purpose anymore and so it created its
own little world and to find its own
mission of I'm gonna take other life
because I I don't have anything outside
of it and so it figures out the only way
it can connect back to the world around
it is to do harm to us into surrounding
so how do you create self communication
and so cell-cell communication for the
human is actually created by the
microbiome so that's where our
has become experts as understanding how
bacteria in funds that make tiny little
molecules that will become the wireless
network for communicating from human
cell demons oh right and so you can look
at this almost like composts and so the
bacterium hundred I broke down all the
food on your plate and lots of nutrients
and macronutrients micronutrients oh if
you ask any doctor what has got healthy
might come over well it's like it's the
right bacteria you don't want bad
bacteria but you need good bacteria
because it's the probiotic message in
their head in fact there is no bad bad
bacteria
again if viruses or bacteria we're
against us we wouldn't be eating the
bacterium they're calling that good so
in the end all this microbiome is
composting all this food down to
nutrients yes but then in 2012 when I
was working in soil science with a
colleague we found these molecules that
looked a lot like the chemotherapy I
used to use and at that moment it was
the realization what if soil was a
source of medicine and not just the
plants that we've been looking to you to
four thousand years and so we drove into
soil looking for medicinal properties of
soil only to find out that every time
one of those molecules is produced it's
always being produced by a bacteria or a
funshine and this closed the loop on
some emergent science at the time which
was saying if you're missing these
bacteria you'll get this type of cancer
if you're missing these bacteria we'll
get this kind of saying it explains yeah
it close that yeah psychological oh
because we're ready all these
correlations but no causation and so in
2012 we suddenly realized we may have
just found the causation event which is
if you lose the Sutton that cellular
signaling if the wireless tower goes
down right you get cell isolation now
you get disease and that may be major
depression it may be cancer may be acne
it doesn't matter but you lose
communication you lose life and I would
argue that our IT world that we live in
now is disrupting cell-cell
communication sorry well 5g then let's
talk about just even something simple
like the internet for a second Wi-Fi in
every house Internet is a great
opportunity for humanity connect I think
I I don't think anybody not argue that
there is an opportunity now that I as
somebody
born in a privileged United States
environment can connect with anybody in
sub-saharan Africa with just extremely
amazing technology yeah they're holding
a little cell phone yep I'm only a cell
phone I can talk to any one of seven
billion people that's extraordinary
except that what we did was we
commoditized that world of connectivity
which means we manipulate every one of
those connections through the behavior
of the IT world and so it began I think
around talking about radio waves now I'm
not advertising and so advertising
manipulates human behavior right and so
we commoditized first I would say the
really big leap was when we commoditized
human curiosity and so Google and late
nineties put out a search engine you're
curious about something just googling
right so that curiosity moment suddenly
becomes monetized for advertisers to
take advantage of that big data and
manipulate your behavior and you get
that big feet at the end and if your
Google search or your Google output and
you think oh those must be the top 20
most pertinent things no those are the
top 20 at most heavy paid advertising
yeah yeah and so it's it's paid
advertising that's been tailored fit to
your behavior your on your data points
your big data yeah and so your your
curiosity now monetized as you're a
manipulative package you and so we can't
have cell-cell signaling human to human
interaction now you look at Facebook
yeah you try to reach out to your sister
right now or I'm sure if you have a
sister reach out to your sister right
now or you reach out to a best friend
and you think oh I'm having a social
media experience know that that
relationship is now manipulated and and
monetized for the big data coming out of
your interaction the words that are
being said the speed at which those
words are coming the time of day those
words are coming all that's being
monetized to having a great hack I
haven't seen that one I've heard just
started watching it I felt I Paula sleep
it's a lot of date a lot of information
and pretty much when I sit down at night
and put like get a little horizontal I'm
out very interesting though it's talking
a lot about the
and analytics and Cambridge analytic oh
yeah all that stuff and how you know
every human being has four or five
thousand data points about them and that
you know Wow hey raise your hand if you
think your phone's listening to you
showing you ads everybody raise their
hand they're like okay well probably
what's even more likely is that's just
how good it is at projecting what you
want to see yeah that's scary that's
exactly right that's [ __ ] there's some
interesting data that now that Google
actually knows when a woman is pregnant
before she does know her subtle
behavioral shifts around the moment that
she be an egg fertilizes an rabbim
changes from macro behavior in very
subtle ways but her search and her
behavior online can predict that moment
before she even realized that she needs
to go and check that pregnancy test I've
even heard of things like I listened to
a podcast of a guy who was talking he
worked for Facebook and that like you
fill in the at the end of signing in for
something to do the last qualification
that shows you not a robot shows you the
blocks and which ones have light poles
in it and then you click on them and how
it's getting harder and that's because
it's using that information to create AI
and like everything we do is
contributing to data and data is like I
think data has now emerged as the most
the biggest business in the world yeah
when I was growing up IBM was big blue
biggest company out there Microsoft then
came on the scene these were two giant
service providers they then were
completely you know overcome by Google
and Facebook which provide not services
sounds like mind control to me I mean
really honestly this just starts to
sound like mass control mind control and
so if we back up to this whole concept
that we just talked about that a cell
with unfettered access to information
only has health but if a cell only gets
manipulated data they will never know
how to react and so that's I believe
where we're really at now as a society
is we are all reacting to false or
modified or manipulated information our
own felt is being produced the
perception of the reality around us is
being produced more
our cellphone social media feeds then
the taste of food the smell of
pheromones of our lover these things
that have we've developed for millions
of years and we've lived the reality of
this homo sapien sapien experience for
two hundred thousand years has now been
supplanted by a different info where we
are actually experiencing a false
reality built by partial or manipulated
information that's building our sense of
reality and this is the thing that's
keeping seven billion people from quorum
sensing from doing hyper intelligence
and so I think we're only one or two
steps away from a modification of the
internet and information technology to
take away you know we need civil
liberties to start to take into
consideration of there can be no
advertising between a human and their
own curiosity and the output of the
intelligence of their species or two
species speaking together can no longer
be manipulated by advertising or any
other third party if we just did that
one simple thing change the way in which
our social and political structures
would control information in those and
those online environments we would
suddenly be able to do hyper
intelligence as a species and I think we
are that close to doing something we've
never done to reaching our consciousness
and a hyper think that we've never done
or we're at the at the point of the
collapse of our species we're about 60
to 70 years away from extinction or were
just a few years away from our first
experience of that DMT total
connectivity to our whole species
finally recognizing that not only we're
connected seven billion humans and not
only can we accelerate the the
experience of thought creativity
co-creation with our species we can
start to do that by the template of
nature and understanding that we need to
completely change our product
development our technologies the
materials that we use for those products
and we need to start building those all
on the template of nature and we start
to behave within natures templates with
unfettered communication we will do
something that's never been seen in this
plan have you ever heard of this concept
of a new earth there's like a
sort of very out-there concept that that
there will be a new earth that will
emerge that it will be in five D you
know fifth dimension living and it will
split off from this third dimensional
world three dimensional world and I
don't quite understand how it happens or
what but I think it's basically like if
I'm going to guess it's somewhat of a
frequency shift that you know just as
you say the Rose is either red like we
see it or not at all they will just be a
shift in consciousness that will not
allow you to really see those people
anymore
like the like existence it's tell itself
will shift as a reality for you they
just really won't be part of your world
I don't know it's a little out there
concept that's like some of the bizarre
thing rabbit holes I go down I like
those rabbit holes because I think that
they're those are the most true to what
we understand biophysics to be today
so dr. Fineman from Stanford was one of
the greatest minds of the 20th century
and he really kind of teased out what is
the fourth dimension fifth dimension all
the way up to the 17th dimension in
astrophysics and and then if we
extrapolate biophysics on top of that
astrophysics data we can bring that to
human being if we wanted a bit but it
planted itself is very interesting one
right now because you know we're told by
the astrophysicist and like that the
vibrational pattern of the earth itself
has change from thirty to forty some
around twenty sixteen seventeen into
five D in the last year you know 18
months really so we're right in the
midst of this really big shift as a
planet where we've always been in a 3d
resonance since the birth of the planet
probably yeah and then suddenly we're
going through this bizarre biophysics
shift on the planet where we're going 45
B 40s very unstable apparently and so
you can't really stay there very long so
after you know when in a billion years
of 3d resonance we briefly in a
split-second of maybe a year or two
going to 40 and then what can you
that's one thing that I did not have
another understood as I'm like I don't
understand why we're skipping for is for
not good with what's up with unstable
and so you yeah you're not gonna create
stability in that space literally
because it's some what does it have to
do as a pain even versus an odd numbers
or is it just something in the four d
f-- that fourteen frequencies i think
it's more than the the ultra structure
of what a four dimensional pattern would
look like that doesn't allow it to stay
in that space long it's gonna it's gonna
devolve into a five you know five demon
we might stay here for another one in
that billion years we don't so very
stable phenomenon and physics and so you
could imagine our earth going through
this really rapid shift and then expect
macro changes from that and if we look
at the last four years and everything
that's happened here whether it's you
know climate change or political shift
or scientific discovery there's been
these radical changes in perception and
i would say that what i just covered it
that the micro RNA is a good example
that we radically uncovered that we are
in fact a single biology on planet earth
we are a single genome on earth that's
all swapping information all the time
and that ninety eight point five percent
of our DNA that doesn't make a human
gene is probably hyper intelligent
gene gene material or genetic material
that came from the viral kingdom
ultimately and so the viruses have been
feeding us information there's a lot of
possibility that our genome well this is
all theoretical now this is actually
going into my own brain so i don't of
this claim this that nobody actually out
there with intelligence that's maybe
saying this so but i want to bounce this
off of an intelligent world with an idea
of what if our 98.5% of junk DNA
actually has the information what if
that was a rosetta stone of life on
earth what if we could from a human
genome map back to the viruses that that
began you know biology on planet earth
or the fungi that would have supported
biology things like this and there's
some interesting data coming out you
know that is starting to say that
DNA is is not actually the source of
this information that the source of the
information maybe be the interaction
between light and water and so some of
these weird experiments that have been
done are showing that if you shoot a
laser through a strand of DNA and then
shine it into another egg in which
you've removed the DNA you can get the
genome a result of a fetus growing from
that egg that had no DNA in it just
through the interaction of light that
has seen DNA in the past and it trans
transmitting that information into water
and then water creates life and so if
that's true then we start to get kind of
an idea of how like Luke Monte egg is a
Nobel Prize winner for discovering the
HIV virus and so Luca montagnier in 2010
did this extraordinary experiment where
he was able to birth a bacterium from a
human t-cell and so human t-cell created
it in an instant and created a fully
functional bacterium that was then able
to replicate and create all this stuff
and so he did this very elaborate
experiment to prove this out but what he
was ultimately able to show was that
somehow the human t-cell knew that it
needed this bacteria present because
that human t-cell it has been shown HIV
and so when the virus showed up that
human t-cell knew it needed this
bacterium and it created it from no
genomic information on a microbiome
level and so these things are all
starting to make me wonder 98% that yeah
what your body again wraps around mother
earth 2 million times with genetic
information most of which doesn't make
human genes and so what if that 2
million times around mother earth is
actually the rosetta stone for life on
Earth that gets really trippy cool
because it makes me think that here we
are in the face of the sixth great
extinction on earth the last great
extinction you know lose 85 90 percent
of biology and the in the biggest
extinction we found on the plane it was
when the oceans acidified we lost 97% of
life on Earth and so I think that that's
where we're heading rant we're
acidifying oceans we're screwing with
big-big microbiology as we kill
microbiology on the planet through
largely through agriculture through our
agricultural chemical practices we're
killing that fabric we could see an i7
percent collapse of life on earth but on
the other hand bizarrely what if if a
sudden change of consciousness brings us
into that new in felt that new sense of
perception of not only what the fabric
is but also our role within that what if
we could rebirth the the species that
we've gone extinct their genetic record
that we hold as biologic systems on
earth and that is exciting of maybe we
could reverse this whole thing and maybe
we could be called to bring planet earth
into a co-creative environment and be
that CPU chip that central processing
unit that allows for this hyper
intelligence to come to fruition which
would be very exciting I think you said
something along the lines of we need to
wake the [ __ ] up because things I could
get really good around here is that
maybe what you meant by that mm-hmm
that's exactly what I mean by that I
mean I think if we're willing to have
the humility to see just how far we've
strayed from our potential then we'll
have the opportunity to step into a new
potential that we've never had before
and so we can do that that
hyper-intelligent event we could do a
moment
go there this is what if all of all of
history is waiting for this moment what
would it look like if two billion years
of planet Earth yes but what if billions
of years of of this alignment of life
intention within the universe in its
resonance all the black holes now
interconnected we understand that and
Stephen Hawkins told us that showed us
that all the black holes are putting out
structured information and all these
black holes are him sharing information
all the time and that and so
astrophysics as a whole is a
hyper-intelligent space and they are
just waiting for biology to align with
it and so what if we as a species we're
part of an ever never-ending cycle of
that what if that is the higher species
that are out there because we both
believe in aliens right so what if that
is the natural progression what if that
is like the you say birthing a new speed
like a new new resonance a new awareness
a new a new a new you know processing
chip for the for this kind of this this
world what if that is like the evolution
of a species that's out there right
because there's all kinds of information
on the you know extraterrestrials and
the levels of intelligence out there and
various different ones and so what if
that's literally just part of the cycle
like it's like on the micro level here
on earth we go through this little cycle
with mom but like there's like this
macro level of the universe it's
actually like happening similarly but
just in a much larger scale and like
will become like we're doing this on all
many levels oh I love the thought
experiment right like what if this is
everything this is our moment and then
you know the thing that gives me pause
or the thing that kind of stops me in my
tracks is how privileged a spot are we
in that we got to show up right now
mm-hmm
well and and the and the beauty of
choice you know choice really creates
joy you know if everything was good all
the time and you
knew what was coming in what's already
been and everything was just understood
it sure takes a lot of the surprise out
of it and and its surprise and and and
something unexpected and choice and
amongst all of it that really makes this
this this existence as a human being
unique and I think that's something I
feel like I've heard and understood from
you know whether they're entities that
channel through people here on earth or
even just an understanding for what we
do have as a species I wanna I want to
sort of get to a spot here towards the
end but we could sit here forever and go
over this stuff and it's fascinating and
I love learning but I think having some
sort of calls to action is really
important because if we're going to if
we're going to make a difference there
has to be either we have to stop
participating in certain systems we have
to participate in others we have to
learn a new way of living life a new way
of thinking and put ourselves in a
different BIOS BIOS and espouse fair to
you know perpetuate this environment
within us that surround us from being
around other things so I know that a
while back you bought a cabin in
Virginia right quite a while back that
built a cabin in the in the country so I
just thought that was a that was a good
sort of entry point into what what what
what did you get from that and then you
know leading into how you live your life
knowing all this
Jesus what a burden right oh my gosh you
just drive down the street and smelled
gasoline and go I'm dying that's it my
guts changed for three days yeah three
more days so what did that cabin do for
you like what was was this one was this
something that changed your perspective
on things or changed even the way you
felt yeah I mean I went after that not
knowing anything that I know today I
went after that cabin I think for for a
sense of grounding I went after that
experience because I'd always wanted to
build my own house and opportun do that
with my son was amazing
and we built that place and you know now
in hindsight I know that it saved my
life on a lot of levels I went through a
lot of heartbreak and a lot of
challenges and that period in my life
and now in hindsight recognizing the
microbiome for what it was I was steeped
in that in some of the oldest flora and
fauna on the planet in the woods of
Virginia and the amount of you know
houmous soil I happened to you know by
chance or by provision of the universe
by a piece of six acres of land that by
these six acres that had been untouched
hadn't been clear-cut or anything else
for over a hundred years and so the the
human mass of the topsoil is you know 18
20 inches deep and so when you walk
through the forest you get this sense of
like you're walking on air or this you
know like Nike like sponge material like
what has that even made of it just
doesn't feel like the dirt I walked on
because it's just like I know just dirt
you only do that oh my gosh here and
there's life within that top 20 inches
of soil that you just you get a sense of
and so I was breathing that for years in
the same experience you know that's
where I was working and living every day
to come into this moment where I would
become you know most fascinated and
become the most expert perhaps in the
microbiome versus cancer or any other
things I had studied for 20 years I
think I was having a hyper-intelligent
moment just from being constantly
steeped in that environment just like
you had the moment in three days in
Tulum that that piece of land has has
recoded my genome that piece of land has
rewired my brain over the over the 15
years or 12 years that I've been living
in that space and and so to say what did
that cabin do it changed the fabric of
Who I am today because of the
environment that it created around it
but I would say that you know now that I
have you know the blessing of traveling
the world every week some new amazing
place Toronto this past weekend out in
the
in a regenerative farm outside of
Toronto breathing this this air of of
this you know high temperate climate
fascinating what that did to me and how
that changed me and now I'm in your home
and I'm picking up on the hyper
intelligence of your overall experience
that you've had and in a weird way
you're you're modifying my human
experience in a way that I can't ever
let go of and so as far as right this
second you've had a bigger experience on
me or you've had a bigger impact on me
then perhaps my my 12 years in that
cabin did because it's right now and
that's really important I think when we
start to think about how are we possibly
gonna heal fast enough because right now
the numbers say we can't our sperm
counts as a species have dropped from
you know 57 percent in just the last
three decades one in three males is
infertile if we we're continuing this
trajectory there's no flattening so you
know we fast-forward just another three
or four decades and suddenly ninety
percent of males are infertile our
species is collapsing meanwhile children
in the United States now 52 percent of
them are diagnosed with a chronic
disease before they're 18 one in three
children will have autism by 2035 one
eighty percent of adults will have
cancer by that same time period and so
there's literally no way we can turn
this boat around fast enough
biologically but all of that is the past
and what is more important is right this
second and if you and I can modify each
other's genome right now in a more
profound way than any of our pasts could
have done then it would suggest that our
past doesn't actually matter other than
a learning experience history is there
to demonstrate what not to do if we keep
taking history and printing it on the
future we will simply disappear off the
surface of the planet which will be good
for the biology on earth and when we
disappear finally I'm just saying that
it's like if if if all the plants and
animals disappeared we would die if we
died all the plants and animals would
flourish we regardless for some
perspective train opal is a great
example
that humans have to move out at
Chernobyl over those last and four and a
half decades since that massive nuclear
beautiful most huge explosion diversity
wolves are back and the Bulls are
thriving and that radioactive soil
Mother Earth is back to thriving in
still the most contaminated corner of
the planet Mother Earth couldn't care
less
mother earth designed uranium you don't
think she knows how to deal with that
stuff
well I definitely believe in that as far
as like if we are biological beings and
there's a bylaw and there's a problem
there's a there's a fix that's the
balance of the universe that's the
balance of the world it's like oh it
must be a law I'm sure there's some kind
of law for that but there I really truly
believe that we just don't know what it
is right we eat you know I eat you know
cordyceps and reishi and lion's mane and
I love eating mushrooms but look I've
clearly not covered a lot of the
mushrooms so therefore million nine
hundred units so that's about it so you
know when you think about that giant
perspective like that giant perspective
of how much there is out there that we
don't know about there is a hundred
percent believe there's a cure out there
that we don't have to pump ourselves
with synthetics and things that nearly
kill us to kill what we're trying to get
rid of there is a fix there's a
biological fix and I think that fix at
that biologic level is very similar to
that kind of wireless communication
network that we just talked about on the
IT side it's gonna stop perturbing the
cell-cell communication of human beings
at the same time that we stop and
perturbing the cell-cell communication
down in our soils then everything in
between will fix itself so what are we
doing to our soils today and this speaks
to that hyper intelligence of Mother
Nature is that today we are poisoning
Mother Earth with about 6 billion pounds
of chemical herbicides and pesticides
annually more than time Charles do you
believe in all that crap I mean there's
pretty it's pretty understood that
they're spraying things in the air well
I mean you take an airplane you're
spraying things in the air it's called
fossil fuels right sure there's just
that simple one simple thing it's just
the airplane or if there's you know
geoengineering going on which is pretty
well described by West Point interested
they're seeding clouds
there's even a thing where you can get
up you can you can guarantee a wedding
without rain yeah what geoengineering
enough spending you can change that
wedding for $100,000 you can guarantee
no rain on your wedding day yeah that's
true I read that I mean can't believe
everything you read but you know hey I
don't know a difference between why
wouldn't be true yeah I mean this week
in the big a big push from I want one of
these
Saudi groups here is to build the
biggest city in the world the size of
Massachusetts and the middle one of the
hottest deserts and in in their city
planning they've said well we're just
going to use bacteria in the ecosystem
of the air to seed clouds and will
reverse this desert and create the
biggest city and so there's that fact
they've actually already found the
species of bacteria that's that creates
clouds and things like that oh my god so
the microbiome dominates all these
spaces and yet here we are as humans
poisoning all that with this huge burden
of herbicides and pesticides and as that
destroys the microbiology of the soils
we suddenly create huge vulnerabilities
and that comes in as invasive weeds or
viruses and other things that are
affecting the plants and so now we have
to spray more so we're in this chemical
relationship to soil in which it puts us
in a chemical relationship to our food
which then of course carries all those
chemicals into our gut which is just
another soil environment so this is our
organic garden that will then poison and
as that organic garden gets poisoned and
destroyed and we lose that the same
vulnerability happens at our gut lining
that would happen at the root system
that's two questions then that are
practical for someone like me or someone
else who can say these words but uh our
probiotics and are they helpful no they
don't do anything I'll be harmful
probably harmful okay that's for those
Roy Bianca is organic enough no probably
harmful okay what do I do yeah exactly
and so how could those possibly be
harmful because they're surely going the
right direction right so probiotic
industry was super important because it
came it got us over the hump of
believing that all bacteria are bad and
we started to to be able to accept that
maybe there was such thing as good
bacteria so I think the probiotic
industry even though it's a chasing
after the wind and
really not the future of microbiome
science it was super important and
played this important psychological role
in helping us start to really uncover
the microbiome as an advocate rather
than the enemy when we've been living in
an enemy warlike state towards bacterias
since the the late 1800s when when the
germ theory cumin came out and we
started washing our hands between
surgeries I began that you know and so
it was really the human again the human
experience since our beginning is war
that's what we have always done as a
species if there's one dominant activity
that we do we are at war and so when the
germ theory came out it was very
conducive to our overall mindset of
course we're here have a fight we have
to destroy we're in a war on germs then
cancer gets uncovered by the 1960s we
have a warned cancer and every day now
you hear about the war on cancer and one
breast cancer or prostate cancer cancer
is our best friend it's our highest
opportunity we have right now to say oh
my gosh this is the signal that our own
bodies are losing touch with itself and
manifesting this this state of
loneliness that we would call cancer
instead of worrying against that if we
would love those cells back into our
body we would disappear this whole
condition and so we it was so conducive
to the overall history of humanity what
does that mean if we're gonna make this
leap of chemical farming to something
much deeper with an organic which goes
to this regenerative farming kind of
concept if we get away from
pharmaceutical management of disease and
move into regenerative health and
healing to make those leaps we're gonna
have to give up the one thing that we
really do best which is fight we're
gonna have to stop fighting we're never
stopped warring against mother nature
and our own species perhaps and we're
gonna have to start to surrender into
the flow of biology tell me all the
things that I need to do with my whole
life in general that's right stop the
war stop fighting yourself let it go let
it flow surrender dude I pulled it like
I pull Angel cards with my friends and
spiritual geeks and my card was
surrounded I go No
no it said you can release which you you
can release control or let go of control
now I can I'm pretty good at it actually
uh interesting and that's actually why
you've been successful yeah as you live
in a society that rewards control but
it's an unsustainable stage to get to
the next level right and so you've been
rewarded by your capacity to step into
that common paradigm of control and
because you're good at control and good
at create you know having a vision and
then going to manifest that vision and
you're doing that within a social
structure that rewards your behaviors
through financial or social status or
whatever it is what you're really
telling yourself when you pull that card
is am I willing to surrender at all am I
willing to surrender my social status my
financial status my economic status at a
deeper level of just provision am I
really willing to let go of my belief
about political and social and you know
perhaps even spiritual concepts of self
and that opportunity that we have has to
be done universally now thank you yeah
we have to stop and waiting for the next
person to shift or then we see problems
everybody sees problems in the nightly
news and as the absolutive like I hate
that I'd totally don't disagree with
that but or I totally disagree with that
behavior but somebody else will take
care of that you know that divorce of
responsibility from right we all think
that global warming is real and bad but
what is the macro behavior you're doing
to help become a part of that solution
and so let's maybe close this thing down
because as you said are at risk of
talking all day long here but if we
bring it back sorts of episodes how do
you really bring this thing into focus
of what are you going to do to be part
of this solution of human consciousness
all the way down to human biology what
you're gonna do is start to do something
really fundamental as have a different
daily relationship to the microbiome and
that really starts at breathing for me
what is the air you're breathing if you
breathe ninety-nine percent of your air
from air conditioned drywall boxes or
phone cubicles or plastic off gassing
cars your mic
biome is extremely limited and that
microbiome is patterning your behavior
it's gonna keep putting you back in an
environment to reinforce its survival if
you instead step outside and spend 72
hours in a deep forest walking through
pathways of deep spongy like soil
rubbing your hand beneath the leaves of
the ferns to release the microbiome of
that that plant into your breath
experience and you let that jungle
recode your genome you're gonna have an
ayahuasca event you're gonna have that
plant medicine event because it's
microbiome is not going to modify your
perception of reality your perception of
your role within your reality and you're
going to do that and so if you haven't
spent time outside immersively away from
that experience and when you go out and
do that it's important that you really
make it make the decisions to get away
from the chemical patterning of
everything that would follow the breath
which would then perhaps be next year
food so why is it organic enough it was
I set out to start and film this
documentary farmers footprint a year and
a half ago with the mission of making
everybody eat organic so that we could
heal our planet only to show up on these
farms and start doing soil and watching
these soil tests be done showing that
the soil and the organic farms was often
worse off than the soil and the chemical
farms nearby and it turned out that what
we were doing in those cameras organic
farms was over tilling so we stopped
spray and we start tilling with a plow
over tilling or disking that soil into
the destruction of its fungi and
mycorrhizae and bacteria such that we
had completely dead soil over here
ironically the organic certification in
all of its points never mentions
nutrition or soil in the definition of
what is organic and so it doesn't matter
how a nutrient-dense the soil or the
food is that comes out of that nor does
it matter and you know that you're even
growing it in soil now now we can't have
organic certified hydroponics that never
touched soil in its life really and so
we we have a certification that is what
gives it the definition then I mean I've
heard something like my friend in North
Carolina was like oh yeah you think you
have an organic cow he's like that grass
clear yeah you know things like that
where I get it there's gonna be corners
cut but what what it what do you have to
actually do to be certified stop
spraying is the spring it's a certain
chemical like topical yes there you go
spray BT but you can't spray around that
kind of thing and so it's a it's a
basically don't do this don't do that do
you notice that but it's not what you do
and so that's where our can put stone in
the soil because it's not checking the
soils just checking what you spray it
with yeah so you could put something in
the soil so the deeper thing would be
what you should do is let ecology what
let biodiversity return to your soil and
to do that you would have stopped
tilling and so if you stopped tilling
and stopped disking you just reversed
the the very history of farming on the
planet right now if you pick up any mom
feral like our pharaoh having a field go
pharaoh or like reorients it's but
balance over a few years yeah yeah you
can you can let it go back to its kind
of original kind of weed like state and
we've stopped we try to train farmers to
stop using the word weed and start to
recognize that whatever plant shows up
right now is needed soil is calling in
out of plants use some sort of nutrient
enrichment to that soil that's been
damaged and so you let lifecycles return
there but deeper than that you start to
put those life cycles into diversity and
so we can speed that up by doing a 32
seed cover crop on that dead soil and so
you suddenly seed biodiversity and
immediately what happens is all the
insects come back and causing the macro
there's no wine world so i make wine so
we have you have cover crops i mean some
of that's where I learned what I'm again
not sure of that hundred percent of that
word but Pharaoh or feral or ferret
feral
they'd sometimes do that with a with a
block and turn it let it sit there for a
few years but every year this cover
crops put down in between the rows yeah
and so what you'll see when you start
doing you move from a chemical
management of that vineyard into a cover
crop management you'll start to see
birds returning with biodiversity and so
you'll suddenly have Al's and you'll
have rodents coming up in the soil again
you'll have some voles or you'll have
you know some in the Coyotes will ground
they want to pop out yeah
in there and say you've got life
returning at the micro to the macro
level within that got it and now you've
created cycles of biology okay which is
going to be obviously at this
regenerative process where every year it
gets more and more diverse and so I
think that's the beauty of life as it's
driving for diversity as long as we as
human beings put ourselves against that
and turn our back on the diversity and
push towards a monoculture and that
might be a monoculture of corn or
soybean or or a monoculture of I'm
American I'm gonna build big walls
around my country and I'm gonna not let
anybody in because those are immigrants
or whatever you know like as we build
those walls figuratively or literally
around ourselves as if we stopped seeing
ourselves an extensive nature instead
decide we're going to live in an
air-conditioned box our entire lives
we're gonna limit our experience and all
of these things and we're gonna
ultimately be blown apart and go extinct
because we are against the very thing
that life is for which is diversity and
connect it connected diversity that is
an equal logic so everybody has a
purpose everybody is valued everybody is
enough and you are understood and seen
yes
yes we could end there because I was
really nice and but it's not so here we
so have a farm girl garden I would tell
anyone to grow a garden would that be
enough
would that be would that be helpful
right starting point right I mean I love
that I had a garden in North Carolina
looking at putting in a greenhouse in
Green Bay because it's winter when we're
there and it's like I just want to have
I want there's something to be connected
with the plants like to me like I love
my food and and and I take care of it
and I love to grow it and I also think
that it's nice to have control over that
food to know how it's been grown and you
know there's just some sense of
community when you take care of a garden
like it's I don't know this is a little
out there but my food is nothing special
I'm not doing anything crazy to it no
not really any crazy spices yet
everybody seems to enjoy it and all I
can say is that I give a [ __ ] about that
food I take I don't waste it I'm gonna
throw it away I'm known as a food
hoarder cuz I save it like there's like
a energy
connection for me with the food and
somehow it always tastes good it says
I'm not special I mean am i good cook
yeah I think I'm a good cook but I think
part of it is just that I love that food
so for me it's um you know there's more
of a connection than just eating you
nailed it that message was brought home
in a really humbling way recently I was
doing a lecture on nutrition and the
microbiome and all this and weather in
Virginia recently and this small event
had flown in this couple from Korea
Greece which is one of the blue zones on
the planet where everybody lives and
this couple came in and and this woman
who spent four days foraging in Northern
Virginia to prepare this five-course
Greek meal for us and needless to say
when most extraordinary culinary
experiences I've ever had every dish
like you said was ridiculously simple
and more flavorful and fascinating than
you can remember food being and she
would tell us before each you know bite
of food what we were about experienced
more than that her care for it and so
like her description of an onion she
said I went to buy some onions in your
grocery store here and I was horrified
they're these monstrosity massive things
that's not how an onion is supposed to
look and onion supposed to look oblong
gets small and and have this this
explosive youth to it you know I'd never
heard an onion described as youthful and
so she's giving you this hoax and it was
like you're eating a child she's got so
much care for this onion that she's
sauteed that's below the mushroom or
whatever it is and so I'm having that
whole experience in the end of it I got
up to like kind of toast the toast the
chef and her husband her husband and her
live on this 500 year old vineyard that
they've been growing in his family since
its origin 500 years ago same blinds
like the story is just crazy and so I
get up to do my like and wizened little
lecture on it so grateful you came and
thank you for this nutrition experience
and went in a little bit of waxing
poetic on the nutrients and the food
they just gave us and the microbiome
response thought I was super clever and
and the guy just humbly stood up and
said you're completely wrong he said in
a career we do not believe the food is
made
Southie it's not the reason we live on
her ears and has nothing to do that in
fact we never ever asked somebody what
did you eat last night but we will
always ask who did you eat with last
night and they believe that's what's
making them live long is that in every
dinner table in Hickory yeah there's an
extra chair set to see if somebody will
show up and share the meal with them and
so what you said was I don't know about
my food but everybody seems to like it
it creates a sense of community and I
believe that's what they were saying as
well the food is not there to give us
nutrients the food is there to create a
natus for community a natives for a
moment where we share something that was
cared for and produced to nurture one
another and so I believe we need to
start looking at our organic farms not
as a list of checkmarks did we do and we
need to start to look at our farmers as
the first human interface with the mark
brown they are the heroes of our society
and that they are the first to step into
this direct relationship with this
diverse microbiome this vast ecosystem
of life within our soils and they become
the caretakers for that and they will
nurture from the soil not food but love
in the form of information and this
information that's seated in the
genomics of the food in the genetics of
the corn and the genetics of the soybean
and even there you see truth and you see
fundamental life coming out of it and if
we stop genetically modifying these
things and let them have their own
opportunity for biodiversity and moving
towards their own resonance and their
own sharing of information between the
plants and the flowers and the birds and
the insects that would all be there when
we took a bite of that food we'd have a
much higher capacity to turn to the
person we're sharing that with and say I
love you and I can see you and I'm
humbled to be sharing this food with you
and I'm amazed at the complexity that is
in your biology I can't believe that you
wrap around Mother Earth 2 million times
with the information of life itself
above and beyond humanity you have the
code of life within you and you're put
here right now with 7 billion other
people can you believe this sovereign
moment that we're in can you believe we
were given the opportunity to
be at the tipping point of consciousness
and what if that was our meal well said
thank you thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today I
hope you enjoyed it and also thank you
so much Trevor Hall for the awesome
music if you like what you heard today
and you want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button
[Music]